we got the story from the AP Alex Jones
ordered to pay 473 million dollars more
there you go to Sandy Hook families so
uh 1.44 billion okay Connecticut Judge
Barbara Bellis imposed the punitive
damages on the Infowars host and Free
Speech system Jones reportedly told his
millions of followers yeah you get the
point the record clearly supports the
plaintiff's argument the defendant's
conduct was intentional and malicious
and certain to cause harm by virtue of
their infrastructure ability to spread
content and massive audience including
info Warriors I think it's all lies I
think Alex Jones is a guy who goes in a
show and says things he thinks and he's
often wrong and he has free speech
rights to do it he doesn't have a free
speech right to defame people but I
believe he only defamed one person
explicitly I do think he was wrong to
say this and I do think it does did
cause damages but this court in my
opinion has delegitimized Itself by
saying a gajillion bajillion Mega Bucks
they may have well just said you know
the meteor made of gold it's just it
doesn't exist it's not going to happen a
death penalty why don't you just give
him the death penalty I mean I mean yeah
it's not that far off and and of course
you know he wasn't right sometimes and
he he did get a lot of criticism but he
also apologized for what he did uh so
again first they try to science to
Second they try to take you down through
legal means and third they totally take
you out I think we're in the second
phase here I think what's happening to
him is is insane is is crazy I was even
critical of him a few years ago but but
again if they're doing this to him why
can't we do the same to the corporate
media like but are they going after him
because I mean I feel like I mean what
it what is their point is it because he
was one of the outspoken people for
Trump just like Steve Bannon I mean
they've gone after every single person
that has been influential in the Maga
movement and he has a huge fan base
Steve Bannon has a huge fan base they
went after Roger Stone they went after
Mike Flynn they've literally taken down
everybody Milo they've taken down
anybody that's been associated with
Trump and they go oh look look at all
these indictments I mean even if it has
nothing to do with them but it's just
like they wipe out one of them at a time
with process crimes with not compliant
or whatever Steve Bannon did I mean it's
just little tiny things but just to say
Hey look anyone who supports Trump yes
they target yeah man it's it's so crazy
how many media personalities who had big
shows and supported Trump gone you know
and that I mean and unrelated I'm a big
DeSantis fan I never liked to try out
his head is all the way
but it's true when we look at the online
social media presence and and the memes
and the supporters of Donald Trump they
were the ones that got him into office
that's what I think they were the ones
who stood up and said hey this is
absolutely crazy here's some memes
here's a point of view here's my hot
take on this issue and it was
individuals like Loomer like Milo like
Alex Jones like Bandon that were there
on the Forefront that represented a huge
anti-establishment wing and slowly and
surely they were being taken out by The
Establishment as Donald Trump was kind
of watching it all transpire and didn't
decide to intervene and help out his
supporters which is another criticism of
him that I think is legitimate because
he had the power to to to just not only
just say something but to intervene to
pass executive orders to pass laws but
to more importantly also help set up
other infrastructure and other platforms
when when he saw all of his supporters
being censored and and and banned
everyone was telling them you're going
to be next he couldn't do an executive
order well he could have done a number
of he could have just try and invigorate
a different platform like he's doing now
exactly it's too late he could have went
to parlor right or he could have went to
truth social but he didn't do any of
that as people were telling him but
people were coming on to gab or mines
and I remember I was at the social media
Summit and someone stood up and said why
don't you sign up for an alternative
platform he goes which one which one and
then people were like there's there's a
bunch but I I guess my understanding is
uh Kushner told him not to do it not to
go to parlor well and was it Kushner
that um helped put elect or put all
these people in positions around him
that completely filled him like Jeff
sessions and no you know was I mean if
there's like one criticism I have of him
rounded himself with people I guess it
was just to appease and make himself not
look like he was coming in and just he
said he was going to drain the swamp but
he didn't
yeah you know he surrounded himself with
almost very swampy and and I think he
got in there and realized just how deep
that swamp was or at least how wide it
was it and it was it was a lot and he
didn't have the people who were going to
pull around him I mean that's for sure
and he hasn't been the best human
resources manager in that regard he
definitely put the wrong people around
him but that probably would be really
overwhelming going in there with so many
people against you to know exactly who
to trust well you're going in as a
businessman yeah not as a politician
you're not you're going in there you're
not willing to you know shake hands and
put your arms around everybody else and
say I'm going to scratch your back you
scratch mine and that's a very
Elementary way of saying what goes on
but there is an element of that you know
you're going to do me a favor I'm going
to do you a favor he went in there like
a bull in a china shop unfortunately I
think
I God God I don't care if people come
down on me on this but I mean Trump went
in there to drain the swamp and end up
ended up becoming very swampy well he
didn't have the infrastructure around
him I don't think he becomes and I think
he became he did not well well it
depends uh operation warp speed and all
these other things it's all it's all on
people's personal beliefs and and at the
end of the day people will decide what
they think of him uh on their own
personal political uh ideas but uh well
one thing that I did want to bring up is
that he didn't have the infrastructure
and he went along and I think he should
have fired a whole bunch of people he
should have been like there's a lot of
bureaucracy here I don't know who you
are you're probably going to screw me
over you're probably going to leak to
the media fired you know it's a clean
house I think the answer to that is and
is it what do you all have like a
Beltway here or something like you need
to if if he's elected again or does
Santa's all the people they surround
themselves with needs to be like out of
this DC area yeah bring it inside get
some people from like Minnesota or I
don't Texas I would rather see blue
collar workers at the White House
bureaucrats that were there eliminate
everyone just get get like get get coal
miners be like hey you're going to be in
charge of the EPA
people have done this [ __ ] yeah yeah I
mean you know you got you said people
from Texas I said just not Rick Perry
you know I didn't know the guy who says
Let's abolish the department of energy
and then they put him in charge of the
Department of energy yeah not good
amazing yeah well but yeah but God I
really like y'all I should run for
office like as a Democrat because I
can't finish sentences
yeah but you're cute I know
you do no no the thing the thing there
is and when I say he got Swampy the the
whole deal is
like you said operation warp speed yeah
the you know until Trump comes out and
says I I was wrong he's never going to
do that but he pushed he pushed he
pushed he pushed he did it to appease he
pushed the vet and he still say that
word I don't even know the procedure
he brought the CEO
Johnson out on the road
the rain he makes a lot of money and the
place booed Bill Gates is bragging right
now saying I told Trump not to
investigate the procedure he did it I
was telling him how to implement
policies and he wanted me to become the
science sir that's what Bill Gates is
saying today Donald Trump desperately
wants to take credit
he will not back down from that no he
wants it to be his great Victory he
won't back down he's his his I don't
know like people like his ego I guess I
don't understand that opponent of it you
wouldn't want to be married to that
right I don't understand why you want to
be you know you don't want to that you
don't want that guy to be your neighbor
but again and I think there's a big
portion of Americans out there that are
conservatives that do not want
government intrusion in your life they
got locked down lost their jobs you know
people screaming for reparations there
need to be there needs to be pandemic
reparations I mean that Emily Oster that
wrote that article last week or whatever
Halloween for the Atlantic said there
needs to be pandemic anesthesis amnesty
screw you there I mean until there's
real true reparations for that people
restored to their jobs there's there's
you know unless you can bring Grandma
back and you can't uh and and I look at
that and I'm like Trump was a part of
that yeah he was a part of that he was a
part of allowing the he allowed fauci to
go too far I don't think he knew I think
a lot of people but see again that's the
argument that people I knew I I knew and
I'm nobody I knew yeah I knew Dr fought
you a soul of crap yeah as soon as he
was implementing policies saying black
lives matter protests are great and they
don't spread to the virus but but
lockdown protests are dangerous and we
shouldn't be doing those so so as soon
as that happens Donald Trump should have
been like hey what are you doing why are
you saying black lives matter protests
are okay but anti uh you know lockdown
protester
is not okay exactly you can't go to
weddings you can't go to funerals so so
legitimate question then like what about
Trump made him completely blind to Black
we saw the riots happening in the George
Floyd riots how why didn't Trump he we
we knew it was bad we knew Tom Cotton
said Insurrection act Trump did nothing
wasn't there at least out so outside of
trump not taking action on the rights
wasn't there an obvious contradiction
when you couldn't go outside because of
the lockdowns and even Trump was was
advocating for them I tweeted this
recently Donald Trump ragged on Sweden
over not locking down Sweden has had
less excess deaths and they didn't the
least amount yeah performance is one of
the best in the world where was Trump's
mind and lockdowns are important I am
not going to do or say anything about
these black lives matter protests yeah
the scientists came out and were like
yeah it's it's well the establishment
scientists well that's propaganda
newspaper yep there are lives of
Colorado they're like you you see when
when people protest for Democratic
causes this helps everyone with coven
but when they when they when they
protest things that that we don't like
that's bad and it was so bipartisan it
it's so partisan excuse me it was so
partisan it was so biased it was such a
slap in the face to anyone paying
attention and I I don't think Donald
Trump didn't see it coming I think it
was more obvious than ever I want to
point this out because we're going to go
to the next segment but uh you know and
I was thinking about Alex Jones having
to pay 1.4 billion I was like wouldn't
it be awesome if he won that Powerball
you look at that I mean that that's
basically a death penalty here's a guy
who he can't pay a billion and a half
dollars off you can't do it I don't
think it's anywhere near that look
they're not going to get a penny from
them and it's not going to stop him no
he's gonna look there there's already
other people he's worked with running
companies right doing similar things I'm
buying supplements right now we get it
we get it Alex is they're gonna say you
can't have money and he's gonna say but
someone else can have money and that's
how it's always been he could oh so
what's he gonna do start a new C Corp
and the C corp's got money and you can't
sue the C Corp yeah look they'll they'll
try they'll Sue they'll file they'll
file they'll file they'll never stop but
they're really not going to get anything
from him thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time